[音楽]
[拍手]
お集まりいただきありがとうございます声
なき声を音にするというテーマで話させて
いただきますよろしくお願いしますまず時
は遡って私が17歳の頃ですね
ある1人の好きな女性がいましたそして
その女性が好きになり
告白しましたが振られましたここまでだっ
たらものすごくよくあるただ普通の高校
生活の中であるストーリーだと思うのです
がここで心に
穴が開いた私が向かったのは花屋さんでし
たそして花屋さんにトマトをとぼとぼ
近づくにつれ1匹のとてもかわいい回転率
を見つけ
好きになりましたそれももちろん性的に
勝つ恋愛的にですさてこうなった状態の私
の頭の中には何があったでしょうかと言い
ますと一つだけどうやったらこの子と関係
性が持つことができるのか何かしらの関係
性特別な関係性をこのハエトリスだと思っ
ていなかったとその前に
我々人間と植物の関係性ってそもそも
どんなものがあったっけっていう疑問に
行き着いたんですねそこで人間と植物の
インタラクションのものすごく快適な整備
というものを始めましたその結果
縦軸をインタラクションの結果が確認
できるまでにかかる時間の長さそして横軸
を人間優位なのか植物優位なのかそして
その双方向的なインタラクションが行われ
ているのかという二次元の
図にプロットすることができまして
仮にそれを動物でやってみるとこんな感じ
になるんですね動物でやっています例えば
愛学ってなるとものすごい短い時間軸で
ある程度双方向的なインタラクションが
確認できる中
観察となりますと人間側が見る方向は変え
られるけど動物は常に動き続けそれに従わ
なければならないという意味でかなり動物
優位なインタラクションとなっていますし
実験だったり
畜産に至ってはものすごく長い時間軸の中
で人間優位に働くようにできている形だと
思っています動物に関して言えばここら辺
の
短く
双方向的なインタラクションがかなり多く
てそれもまあ動物っていうのは僕たちに
働きかけが動きのある形でできるわけです
からあのここら辺が多いのかなってなって
いるのですが
植物に
至ってはここら辺がすっぽり開いちゃっ
てるわけですね
ものすごく文句が人間優位となっていて
盆栽などでしかその双方向性のある
インタラクションというのが確認されない
じゃあここの部分がすっぽり抜けてしまっ
ているとでこの短期的かつ双方向的な
インタラクションの欠落の結果何が起こっ
たのかと言いますと植物は生きていること
は感じづらいというような問題が起こった
わけですねそれ実際に目標を持ってるだけ
じゃなくて今までの言葉だと調べていくと
明らかにそうだよなと思う言葉いくつか
ありまして一つがこのアリストテレスが
残した
植物は定型の魂を持たず生としての境に
なっているというような自身の植物につい
ているという論文で残した言葉であったり
はパスカルのパーセンに至った人間は
考える葦であるこれまさか本当に汗が考え
ていないかのことを前提にした発言ですし
僕の天井見た僕サイズが
葉っぱで生きてるんですねでものすごい
大きい声で言って
きたんですこれじゃあ今まで君は生きて
るって感じじゃなかったのかいっていう風
に思ったわけでこのように
植物を無機質かつ生きていないように扱っ
てしまった社会に生きてる中で僕どうやっ
たらこの
植物を生きているという風に再現して
いけるのかということを考え始めました
そこで
欠落していた短期かつ双方向の
インタラクションの技術的に実装すると
いうことで共演という形の
インタラクションに注目して開発したのが
こちらの細胞ですこちら何かと言いますと
植物と共演できるシンセサイザーでして
仕組みを話すと
植物のイオン
で流れる整体電位を電極で取得してそこ
から取れたデータを元に
植物のモジュラーシーズンの共演すると
いうようなものとなっております
[拍手]
植物の両面に流れているイオンチャンネル
の
中を通ってる電気の動きでしてこれが
研究でによると周囲の環境だったり台車
だったり空間情報
めちゃくちゃ余談なんですけど人が部屋に
入った時に変化があったみたいな
緊急結果もあるみたいでそのようなデータ
が反映されるものとなっておりますそして
それに対してモジュラー申請というのは
様々な機能を持つモジュールというものを
ケーブルでこちらケーブルたくさんあると
思うんですけどこんなものでつないで一つ
の音を作れるというSSになります例えば
音を出すモジュールというものがありまし
てそれに対して音色を調節するモジュール
があるとまた音程を調整するモジュールが
ありそれにリズムを作るモジュールがある
それら全ては一つ組み合わせてことという
ものを作るんですねなんでこんな
まどろっこしいことをいちいちやってるか
かと言いますとこれによって何ができる
かっていうのも細胞肉の構成を話しますと
3つのドラムがありますで3つの
ベースライン
変更できる変数があってそして最後にC
スタイルのこの3つの要素で変更できます
とここのそれぞれの要素それぞれの要素を
誰か人間と植物どっちが演奏するかって
いうのをあらかじめしっかり決めた状態で
演奏することができるんですねこれによっ
て
植物と人間の共演に
そのままその場で最もふさわしい形って
いうのを模索しながら
演奏を続けることはできるというような
ものになっております例えばですね
こちらで音を出しますと
例えば
[音楽]
こんな感じの簡単なメロディーが作れる
わけなんですけどこちらどういう状態かと
言いますと音程もリズムも音色も全部
植物にはコントロールしている状態となっ
ておりますそれに対して
ここのリズムのコントロールする部分を
一旦取り外してしまいまして
植物にコントロールさせることもできるん
ですねでそれを色々入れますとこっちに
入れてこっちの方が電極をこういう風に
貼ってあげますと
こんなふうに非常に
複雑なランダム性のあるリズムが植物に
よって生み出されるわけでありましてこれ
らを組み合わせて一つの音楽を作って
いけるというようなものとなっております
このようにコントロールできるとでそして
この開発が終わった後様々な場所で作った
だけで自分の家の中に置いとくのも
もったいないのでパフォーマンスを行って
いきましたその中で特によくコラボしてい
たのが稼働家の人であったり盆栽をやっ
てる方でして
普段
植物をよく切ってる人たちがどういう風に
感じるのかなっていうのを聞いてみた
ところまあやっぱりあの音楽といけばな
つながりも食物を生きることを問題意識を
改めていろいろ考えさせるようになったと
いうようなきっかけが作り出したんじゃ
ないかなっていう風に思っていますでこれ
からの話をします今後は何やってるかと
言いますと実は僕が作った
共演っていう形のインタラクションは非常
に短い時間軸で
双方向的なものができたっていう風に感じ
てるんですけどここの部分
植物優位かつ置換術が非常に短いというの
が僕いまだに見つけれなくて今度ここを
もうちょっとそっちにずらして開発するっ
ていう風に思っていまして今作っているの
が
植物に塩素を邪魔されるというような体験
です見た目普通のピアノに植物が置かれ
てるだけなんですけどそこのピアノを押し
ていくと何かなぜかたまに音程が
ものすごくずれるとそこのコントロールを
全部植物にやらせることにやらされること
によって完全に彼らから働きかけをもう
ちょっと分かりやすい確率でできるんじゃ
ないかなという風に考えていますという
わけで最後に一つだけメッセージを残して
帰りたいと思いますまあこちら
ニンジンとバナナ食べてますね非常に
美味しそうですそしてこちら
植物の石一切関係なしに我々が自然なトス
を作りたいと言って増え始めた街路図
そしてこちら
食卓に寝られたトマトですねこちらみんな
に生きてるわけなんですよそのことを
覚えて皆様の植物とのインタラクションに
何かしらの揺らぎが起こったり非常に
面白いなっていう風に考えております以上
ありがとうございました
[拍手]